wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
mein bruder hat sich total verändert
die letzten wochen großartig mit
apropos großartig
ich habe ein paar gute tipps für dich
damit auf dem bewerbungsgespräch wie
machst du das
ich habe eine zusage für das praktikum
wirklich warum hast du mir gar nichts
erzählt von den waden das
bewerbungsgespräch halte vormittags war
gar nicht so schlimm sondern eigentlich
sogar ziemlich alle mitglieder so war
ich wirklich gut vorbereitet
sie hat mir gesagt von bei
bewerbungsgesprächen zu überzeugen dass
man auf ein paar sachen zum beispiel du
solltest dich vorher über die ausbildung
und die schule informieren das habe ich
auch gemacht und deshalb war ich wohl
auch gar nicht so aufgeregt und habe
alle fragen sofort verstanden so glaubt
sie haben sofort zugesagt muss ihnen
doch noch ein paar dokumente scheck nahm
schnell anfangen zu können
ich würde gerne aber ich muss jetzt
gehen da man sich rechtzeitig zu hause
wieso ich dachte deine eltern
kontrollieren sich nicht mehr so sehr
ja so war das jetzt auch bleiben
wir sehen uns
[Musik]